we're both turning 40 this year we're
still turning 40. i'm excited
congratulations i think it's i know a
lot of women in the industry get weird
about age i love it i feel like life
gets i don't know exponentially better
like every year i get more comfortable
every year and i get more grateful and
that that i feel like uh staying
grateful is getting is getting easier
and i think i don't know i think that
sometimes a little bit of it is is uh
i've always had friends you're probably
the same way being in the music industry
you've had the opportunity to learn from
so many people that came before so i've
always had friends from uh older
generations and so for me aging never
seemed like a big deal because i've
always had friends those ages yeah and
um but i have lost a few friends have
shifted uh and i realize that i'm over
the halfway point if i go at the same
point as them yeah so the way i'm
holding it is like oh yeah you're
turning 40. you might be closer to the
end in the beginning just get get to the
good stuff yeah you don't know and like
come on
i mean the world is the world right now
yeah so if you have the opportunity to
choose joy then i think we
we are obliged to take it frankly
absolutely i love also that you said
shifted
because i always think it's weird that
people always like um you know friends
we do come there are seasons for some
relationships in our lives and i think
that that's important that that's okay
so i like that you said shifted though
that was really good i don't like to say
that they're lost and by the way i don't
usually talk about the stuff personally
i think i'm turning red you're really
good at what you do but no i like um i
like shifted because it's nice i think
it's i think it's softer and to me it
feels more honest yeah absolutely and
it's cool because this might not that
might not be the end of the story we
don't that's what i mean there's seasons
that's right yeah people do come and go
and i think that that's something i
learned actually it's funny because you
did say because i'm from the music
industry just in the industry in general
i think everybody
there are literally so many different
types of agents like there's so many
generations in what we do like
especially on tour so it's awesome i
think you learn from all of this
different people and i think that people
come and go and it's nice yeah and you
can still be friends with those people
but it's just like a different season
anyway yeah i didn't mean to go there so
you did that to me
[Music]